[Music]
[Applause]
bring in joe lacava the uh tiger woods
county uh where do you want to start joe
you tell me i'll start with the uh right
shoulder left shoulder okay so paulie
wanted to know do you carry the bag on
the right shoulder left shoulder or does
it matter
well for me i'm right-handed so i do
everything right-handed i don't think i
could carry the bag from here to my
front door left-handed okay so there's a
quick story behind that so my best
friend bones
was one of the first guys to go double
strap
and he told me for years and years and
years you got to go double strap
and for years and years i denied it i
just wouldn't do it it just looked funny
to me it felt funky the whole nine yards
and then i think when i got to tiger's
bag later on i was getting older
obviously
and tiger was encouraging me the same
thing you gotta go double strap double
strap it looks easier maybe look awkward
at first but you'll be fine to get used
to the whole nine yards so finally in
2018 tiger actually showed up in
philadelphia third leg of the playoffs
at aeronamic with a double strap on he
got it himself and he actually hooked it
up to the bag so i said oh man now i got
to give it a go
so i give it a go on tuesday we play
nine hole practice run with rory it's
very uncomfortable i can't stand the
thing
wednesday pro am same thing i'm
struggling with this thing i'm dropping
the towel because now it's behind me i
can't really see anything i'm afraid a
club's going to fall out the whole nine
yards so i'm aggravated but i figured i
got to suck it up and do it for the
entire week
we get to thursday tiger shoots i think
62 or 63. he's either in the lead or one
off the lead played great never missed a
shot
so now when tiger plays well obviously i
get a million texts
one of the texts i get is from my son
joe who i we had just gone to james
madison maybe a month ago
he went down the middle of august this
middle of september we hadn't heard from
since in a month i think i maybe got one
text from him so finally i'm going
through my text and i see my kid's name
and i'm so excited that he texts me i'm
thinking myself he either watched the
golf heard about the score saw some
highlights the whole nine yards so i go
down scroll down see my kids name i
scroll down read the text
and all i get is double strap question
mark soft explanation
so there's there's your strap and
there's your right and left shoulder
okay
um
that would you have seen when tiger
misses the cut what's the ratio of blame
for tiger execution
or you in the role that you played
you know when we missed the cut which
isn't often thank god with tiger and
fred over the years um you know i'm one
of those guys i'm the first guy to say
i've never had a chip i've never made a
putt i've never had to drive so all the
credit goes to the player however when
things go bad or south we miss the cut
on that friday night i'll go over and
over and over the stuff that happened
for 36 holes that i might have been able
to do better i always put more of the
blame on myself because as a caddy you
just feel so awful that you missed the
cut and there's no worse feeling in the
world on friday night
and fritzy you were saying that uh do
you second guess yourself have has tiger
been in the middle of a swing and you
think to yourself
oh i should have said seven instead of
eight
well sometimes when you see a flyer come
out of the rough and you're trying to
gauge how fast it's gonna come out and
as soon as he makes contact you're like
oh my god please get down that's like in
the next county kind of thing so you do
have that other rough when you're kind
of guessing as what it is and i make
plenty of mistakes i gotta go back to my
fred couples days we were playing the
71st hold the canadian open at glen
abbey the 17 fold it's a very long green
pins all the way in the back we're going
back and forth seven iron eight iron
seven iron eight or seven and i'm
thinking myself let's get it back to
let's make a birdie let's win this golf
tournament so i talk him into a seven
iron he one hops it into the back bunker
now of course you're feeling awful and
as it always goes with the caddies when
you make a mistake they can never get
the ball up and down to fred's credit he
hit a beautiful bunker shot to about
seven eight feet and of course missed
the putt goes on to birdie 18 and we
missed the playoff by one shot that was
in the middle 90s and i think about that
every day
every day
pretty much yeah i mean that just you
know i mean i make a lot of mistakes
don't get me wrong but that was one i
felt like really actually cost my guy at
least a shot at the tournament if he
makes par there worst case scenario he's
in a playoff
if he makes birdie there and bernie's
18th and he wins it outright so that one
stuck with me for a long time still does
clubs have to stay with you at all times
that that it's your job to get it from
the course
back and then you know the hotel back to
the course every single day
for 20 years yes with fred um the last
10 years with tiger they have club
storage at these places but he does not
leave his clubs here because if there's
156 hecks of clubs in club storage who
are the who's the ones you're going to
mess around with tigers obviously so we
take them every day normally i'll just
load them into his trunk and then he
hikes them up to the hotel the house
that he's staying at but they stay with
him all the time
back in the fred days if i went to play
golf i'd actually use his clubs
have you have you taken inventory of
tigers clubs and something's been
missing
um no not really but i'm a fanatic like
i'll go on first tee and he'll look at
me like really like i'll count the clubs
four or five different times just to
make sure there's 14 in there and i'm
always peeking at the bottom to make
sure charlie didn't leave one in there
because a lot of times they'll play golf
together not so much now because he's
gotten older and bigger but those little
clubs get stuck down in there you never
know what might happen
yeah well that happened didn't ian
wuznum try to take a club out he had two
drivers in the bag at a major and they
try to like disregard it on the first
tee what's funny you say that because it
happened at the british open and you
know most guys obviously it's usually an
extra wedge it's usually if you have an
extra club it's usually an extra weight
maybe a putter because sometimes you
always see the putter with the with the
head covers going on but to have two
drivers in there and not notice that
that's a big blunder um i i tell people
all the time and i'll tell this on the
air if there's 15 clubs in there and i
noticed that on the third tee i'm going
to pretend like i'm going to take a leak
with the bag and i'm going to get rid of
that club in
trust me
he's tiger woods caddy joe lacava
i does it is it weird though like when
did you get to the point where you go i
i'm tiger woods caddy
like how does that work you get the
phone call
because you've carried for a lot of
great people you mentioned freddie
couples but now all of a sudden
here's
the second half of tiger's career
and he's putting it in your hands
yeah that's a great question too you
know i guess being around these guys you
know you're really not in awe of the
guys
and i have a little bit of a reputation
as being very tough on my guys like
unless it's a very spectacular shot i
won't give them any credit at all
like i have very very high expectations
and i think the guys know that and i
think actually tiger appreciates that
because he doesn't want a cheerleader
out there but i'm kind of rambling on i
mean it was a great phone call to get
from tyrone the fact that he was
interested in me um and and you know
like i said 10 years later i understand
i'm on the back half of the career the
whole nine yards but i was around when
he you know we hijacked necklace and
career victories at the memorial
happened to be his tournament and then
when he tied sam sneed and stuff like
that and obviously the master's in 19.
so a lot of special moments um he treats
me you know the greatest thing about
tigers he treats me like a friend and a
buddy i understand that i work for him
and i get that i get that relationship
part of it but i'm more like a friend
than an employee to him which is
fantastic
when's the last time you got yelled at
by tiger
you know i can honestly say i've
probably worked 110 115 tournaments uh
he's never yelled at me once not on the
golf course he may give me maybe give
grief if i if my team's beat his teams
but that's the only time he gives me
grief he's the easiest guy in the world
to work for takes ownership of
when you're walking up 18
or you're letting tiger walk up 18 at
the open championship you know it's been
a struggle you've seen it firsthand
what is your role
and then you got to get tiger kind of
back into the moment here of you know
let's finish this off in style yeah well
my my first point is to stay the writer
stay behind let him enjoy the moment you
know he he appreciated that moment
um a bunch you know he he gets the
history of golf he loves st annuals he
loves everything about the golf
tournament
the fact that he won there twice the
home of golf the whole nine yards i mean
part of him obviously he's very
disappointed the way he played he's nine
over par that's not the way he wants to
finish up on friday afternoon he'd
prefer to be sunday afternoon in
contention i get that part of it but
he's he's smart enough and now he's old
enough and wise enough to appreciate the
moment standing ovation on both sides
the whole nine yards giving the tip of
the hat over the bridge it was a
phenomenal moment um you know like i
said it would be one thing for trying to
make the cut yeah you got to get back
there and you don't want to embarrass
yourself he had a good chip with a
foreign up there about three and a half
four feet and then obviously you're
hoping he makes the cut which he doesn't
but it didn't ruin the moment i thought
it was a fantastic moment for him in
golf when did you realize that you
weren't going to be competitive at the
open championship
um
well it's it's you know it's one of
those things where we just never got
anything going the first day um it
wasn't like he played poorly obviously
mcdouble on the first hole hitting the
divot no excuse he's hidden divots
before um but the putting just didn't
seem to be the short game wasn't quite
there i think he's working so hard to
get stronger and healthier you know he's
working on his long game he's working as
an endurance and there's just think the
short game has been neglected a little
bit at this point and that showed over
there um but you never give up you know
we're sitting there six over par on the
first tee the second day you're still
thinking you can shoot six under par and
make the cut you know the parts can be
even par um so you're still optimistic
but then we got to the turn at you know
seven or eight over you know it was over
so you just try to enjoy the last nine
holes
what role do you play you find out
tiger's been in a life-threatening car
accident
what's the first thing that you do when
you hear that news
uh well the first thing i do is try to
reach out to him and you know the people
around him um i did want to go visit him
in the hospital in la and they said no
it was the height of the virus so they
said
you know the hospitals don't want any
extra people and so on and so forth so i
was communicating pretty much with him
every other day and after the first two
or three days he was communicating
pretty back and forth with me pretty
regularly um so i just stayed in touch
with him and then my wife and i went
down i think in april a couple months
after the fact just to go down there as
friends and let him know he's still got
a great friend and ourselves and we're
supporting him through and through
regardless of what happens with the golf
we just wanted to make sure that he knew
he had a friend around um and then for
the rest of that year same kind of thing
went down to visit him a couple more
times and just wanted to know that we're
in his corner whatever happens or
doesn't happen
but the mental aspect of this because
you can't do anything physically for him
but mentally that role that you're
playing um how would you describe that
well it's again it goes back to the
friendship thing i wanted to know he's
got a friend regardless and i'm not
leaving anytime soon you know i want him
to know that i have faith in him the
good news about tiger is he actually
likes the rehab aspect but he likes to
be in the gym and that's what he likes
to do so he's got a good attitude in
that respect and you know there's
there's obviously some dark days when
things aren't going well yeah maybe has
a setback or two um and i and i told him
i said anytime you want to come down
we'll go fishing whatever we'll hang out
or i'll go watch charlie play golf the
whole nine yards or go watch sam play
soccer i just want to be there as a
friend and support him that way and then
mentally you just got to get in his
grill and
even when he was coming back from the
back injuries and stuff he lost some
confidence in his game so it's all about
building up his confidence again and
letting him know that he's the best
player in the world
did you have to get approval from tiger
to do this interview
no i never even asked him to be honest
with you i just figured you know he he
knows you and he loves the show and
stuff like that he knows you weren't
gonna throw me under the bus or anything
so it's all good
what do you get when he wins augusta
well i get a nice check
um and then you know as a caddy we take
the flag off of 18 that's kind of like
our souvenir which is fantastic for us
and when fred won it in 92
i said you know what i'm going to try
something different here and take the
entire flag and stick and i did the same
thing in 19 when tiger won so i have two
of those sticks along with two of the
flags where are those you get a nice
paycheck are they in there
they're they're uh yeah they're in the
room
can we uh can we see them sure you want
to grab that one in the closet
actually i think i have the why the
tiger flag the flag part in the safe
deposit box in case somebody in case the
health burns down which could happen
oh but i got the fred one right here
i'll show it to you okay
if you can get it on the computer
all right
so here's the flag part of it
but freddie didn't want that
here's the stick he didn't have any
choice
i got news for you
and i'll tell you i'll tell you a pretty
funny story so this is 92 when i was
actually a little bit younger so i'm
walking off 18
and the scoring tent at that time was
right behind the green and i'm so jacked
up so i'm coming off the green and they
have pinkerton has security there and a
pinkerton guy comes up to me goes you
can't have that as private property
and i'm like i'm just baffled that he
would say that to me i understand he's
doing his job and i said i'll tell you
what if you can get it from me you can
have it
and i was so jacked up at the time so
anyways i kept two of these and actually
fred ridley was kind enough to send me a
nice picture of tiger and i on 18
mounted in a nice frame so they've been
very good to me in when the two times
that my guys have won there what's the
most interesting thing in tiger's bag
aside from the clubs
wow that's a good question um
nothing really too interesting i mean
use people don't realize that they use
it the small t's you know today's driver
says they're so big it uses the small
ones not that that's anything unusual
um i always have a couple of peanut
butter and banana sandwiches on
pumpernickel that's a little different
and other than that really nothing
unusual
what do you do now leading up to the
masters
between now and the masters yeah i'll
probably play a lot of mediocre golf
uh but what do you do with tiger oh okay
i'm sorry i don't know what am i gonna
do nobody cares about what you're doing
joe
isn't that the truth yeah um
you know i'm hoping that he will play
maybe in in december at the hero and and
and father-son um and maybe the dentist
i'm still hoping it's
three maybe four terms before the
masters well i i won't do much i'll do
the same thing listen i'll say tiger
listen if you're starting to feel better
you know maybe october november maybe
i'll come down for a couple weeks we'll
hang out you don't have to play every
day i want to practice every day i'll be
i'll be there and maybe give you a
little motivation we'll go down and play
and practice a little bit here and there
and maybe get ready for the hero to get
ready for following year 23 and get him
ready in any any respect that he needs
if i said that the pro had to play with
his caddy and his caddy's score counted
if you were going to handicap who would
be
the best pair on tour
wow great question i know max homer's
caddy is very good and i obviously max a
heck of a player i think scottie
scheffler and uh teddy would make a good
twosome and i think jt and bones would
round out the top three that i can think
of i know a lot of these kids they don't
even know that well good young players
um
if we had to scramble i think tiger and
i might have a shot but it was counting
on our own ball i have no chance but
tiger no matter how good he played
joe great to talk to you and enjoy the
off season maybe we'll uh cross paths
backstage at uh some concert there
sounds like a plan thanks dan i
appreciate it my best to your family
thank you joe thanks dan that's uh joe
lacava tiger wood scouting